hello and welcome to the chicky science
show so in this video
i'm going to address the question can we
edit the epigenome
so since the discovery and development
of crispr cast 9
there has been much hope in editing the
genome not only by inducing
double-stranded brakes
and causing indels to disrupt gene
expression but by homology-dependent
repair mechanisms for precise genome
medicine
it seems certain that genome editing
will be a critical player in the
treatment of genetic diseases
and as a research tool but what about
using crispr cast technology for another
purpose
editing the epig name well we'll be
taking a look at this in this video
but the first thing we need to know is
well what is the epig name
now i could give you a very fancy
definition of what the epg name is
but i think it's better to think about
it this way each of your cells in your
body
has the same dna yet each of your cells
are different
the reason that they're different is
because they're expressing different
genes
and one way that those different genes
are regulated is through so-called
epigenetic marks
and so these epigenetic marks govern
what genes are expressed and this
governs the cellular state
tells the skin cell it's a skin cell or
it tells your liver cell
it's a liver cell and so the key thing
with epigenetics
is that it appears to be heritable so if
that cell divides it still knows that
it's going to be a skin cell
and doesn't suddenly change into
something different and so they're
heritable
and they're not encoded in the dna
sequence which is the same in all of
your cells
and so what differs between different
cell types is the way that that dna is
packaged within the nucleus
where the dna is located within a cell
and so dna is wrapped around
proteins known as histamine proteins and
together they're referred to
as chromatin and so depending on how
tightly packaged
regions of this chromatin is can depend
on how accessible
it is the different transcription
factors and other proteins
that can mediate and activate gene
expression
and what governs the packaging of
chromatin very much depends on the
chemical modifications that can be found
on these histone proteins
but it also seems that modifications on
dna itself
such as cytosine methylation also have a
role in influencing
gene expression and so it is quite a
complicated
thing to try and define and i hope i've
done a relatively good job
but basically epigenetics is important
for influencing what genes are expressed
within a cell
and these marks can be heritable but
they can also be reversible
and understanding epigenetic marks and
their regulation better is of extreme
value
given the fact that epigenetic
abnormalities
have been associated with various
diseases such as cancer diabetes asthma
and fibrosis and also aging itself and
more on from that
it can help to understand other
processes of great interest such as
cellular reprogramming
where you go from one cell type to
another which as
given my definition of epigenetics means
that those epigenetic marks need to be
reconfigured such that that cell that
was thinking it was
a neuron now needs to you know change
those marks and think it's a different
type of cell in this case a stem cell
and so at this point we can come back to
the question of what is epigenetic
editing
and so simply put epigenetic editing is
a way of altering these epigenetic marks
at a specific locus
and the latter part is of most interest
for this video because we're going to
talk about ways that you can achieve
epigenetic editing
by using crispr cast 9 systems and so
what i mean by specific locus
simply means a specific site of dna and
so epigenetic
editing would therefore be technologies
that enable the precise
modification of epigenetic marks at a
specific site
and so chris broadcast 9 is a really
useful system for that
why because the crispr cast complex that
consists of
the protein cas9 and the so-called guide
rna
enable the complex to be recruited to
specific sites on the dna sequence
whereby there are watson quick
interactions between the rna
and the dna and so that provides your
site specific
specificity so specific specificity love
it
anyway whilst the crispr cas9 canonical
system
enables the ability of reprogramming the
guide rna sequence
and therefore the sites in which the
complex targets
in its canonical form it will also end
up inducing a double-stranded break
which isn't really what we want to do
here instead we don't want to change the
dna sequence
we want to change the epigenetic marks
so how can that be achieved
well there are very many many different
ways in which this can be achieved
and it also very much depends on what it
is you're trying to change
as there are many different types of
epigenetic marks
talking about these different epigenetic
marks would literally be a video on its
own
probably a very long video and an
ever-changing video because it seems
that every
month every week there's different
epigenetic modifications that seem to be
uh discovered which is super exciting
but makes it very hard to then make a
video about it
so instead i'm going to give two
examples maybe
focusing on histone acetylation and
histone methylation
but before we take a look at the
different ways in which these
epigenetic modifiers act it's important
to know the similarities between these
different mechanisms
and that's by using the so-called dead
cas9
so what a dead cast 9 refers to is a
cast 9 protein that's been mutated
such that it no longer cuts dna so you
don't get any
single stranded or double stranded
breaks and so that's good because we're
no longer going to be manipulating the
dna sequence but it retains that
programmable dna binding activity
that enables the precision in
epigenetics
and so when it comes to being able to
mediate epigenetic editing
all that effectively needs to be done is
to fuse the cat9 protein
to different enzymatic domains that can
either effectively
write the epigenetic marks or erase the
epigenetic marks
and as i mentioned earlier there's a lot
of research being conducted into
epigenetic editing and
erasing and writing epigenetic marks is
just one way in which the epigenetic
landscape can be influenced through this
approach
but i've decided just to focus on these
two here for now just to keep this video
but
more simplified but if you are
interested i have linked a couple of
really good reviews in the description
in particular this is probably the most
expensive review i could find
and even has beautiful figures anyway
before we look at these examples we need
to understand
we need to discuss what the desired
impact of this editing is
and generally in the case of modifying
these epigenetic marks so far it's in
terms of being able to activate a gene
or to repress a gene to stop it being
activated
and so different epigenetic marks can
either be seen
as being pro-gene expression or
anti-gene expression
so it's better for me to explain this
with some pictures and there's actually
a nice review article that has some very
nice figures
that demonstrates both epigenetic
regulation and terms of repression
and activation and so you can see here
that this is cas9 and this is the guide
rna recruiting it to the
the targeted dna locus and in this case
this cast 9 protein is fused to an
enzymatic domain called lsd1
and lsd1 here actually stands for lysine
specific d-methylase
and so what this enzyme does is it
removes methylation marks
in particular at the histone lysine 4
residue site
and the change from methylation at the
site to
demethylation of the site causes
epigenetic repression
and so it's thought that this
modification could in theory prevent a
gene from being expressed
and that's because by changing these
methylation marks it changes the
proteins that read these marks that come
into the vicinity
and interfering with protein recruitment
can affect the level of gene expression
and so similarly but differently the
example on the right
is of epigenetic activation and this
time
cast 9 is fused to p300 and this
enzyme has the activity of adding acetyl
groups to lysine residues
as you can see here and the addition of
this acetyl group can then bring in
different transcriptional machinery that
can actually activate gene expression
and so the two examples i've just shown
you are in modulating the epigenetic
marks on histone proteins
but you can also do similar things with
affecting the methylation status
of dna in particular the cytosine
methylation marks that i mentioned
earlier
for example in this 2016 paper here they
fused the cas9 protein to a dna methyl
transferase protein
the nmt3a that added dna methylation
marks to cytosine residues
in the proximity of the crispr cas9
complex and so since i've gone down this
rabbit hole we might as well stay down
the rabbit hole
and i think i'll probably talk about
transcriptional repression
and transcriptional activation using a
method other than changing the
epigenetic marks but instead by directly
having domains that can bring in
transcriptional
machinery using crispr cast 9 in a
different video
which i'll probably make sometime soon
but to continue down this rabbit hole
we might as well now talk about the
challenges of precise epigenome editing
and so one of the problems which
possibly isn't a problem
is the fact that there are just so many
different epigenetic marks
and so many different proteins that have
similar enzymatic activities that
effectively do the same thing
a big challenge would be finding the
right protein or
the right enzymatic domain and the right
crispr cas9 system
for the for the job and it goes beyond
just finding the right
epigenetic modification changes to be
made but also
where about the specific site should be
in regards to the gene of interest
and so what i haven't really mentioned
is that if you want to activate a gene
you're not going to target the crispr
cas9 complex so the
gene sequence itself but you actually
target it probably upstream of the gene
which is where the transcriptional
machinery first gets deposited on dna
before it then plows its way through the
dna sequence
during transcription and so there's just
many different ways that you can
manipulate this system
which could have different impacts on
the strength of the
gene activation and then that's the
second thing it's like you can talk
about
gene expression in terms of switching a
gene on or switching a gene off but you
might want to kind of dial up that
expression as well
maybe you don't want a two-fold increase
you want a slight increase
or maybe you do want a really big
increase and there probably is ways in
which
you can control the epigenetic marks to
have that precise control
like the dimmer switch right you want to
be able to dial it up
instead of just flicking the switch on
and off maybe this is just a big side
track but anyway this just would very
much depend on
what it is you're trying to do and then
secondly one of the beauties with
these tools at the moment is that it
just enables us to better understand
these different epigenetic regulators
because you know i've given some
examples where we do know what these
enzymatic domains do but there's still a
lot that we don't know
and there's still other enzymatic
modifications that we don't fully
understand
so yeah one general problem is just
developing the tool and
getting it to the right place at the
right time and then if we want to think
about long term
translating to the clinic then we want
to talk more about delivery approaches
and if you're going to fuse class 9 to
these different enzymatic domains
you've made that castline protein bigger
and these adeno-associated viruses that
can deliver crispr
machinery can only contain so much
dna and so if you increase it by having
these fusion proteins
you might have some problems with
delivery and then the other thing i
haven't really touched upon here is like
in this case we're actually editing the
epigenetic marks
and figuring out what i said at the
beginning of the video epigenetic marks
by definition are heritable
and so what happens if this change was
made in a cell that's going to divide
would it be passed on
so what is the maintenance or longevity
of these different modifications
so if you manage to make it fruity into
that then congrats i don't know how much
sense that even made
but i think yeah the conclusion from
this is like this work is pretty
interesting
and it adds just an additional level of
regulation of what we can really do with
cells
not in terms of therapeutic application
but in terms of further understanding
the components that are already within
ourselves
and i think it will be very exciting to
see what advances are made using these
techniques
and i probably will make another video
at some point going into more detail
about
the alternative ways of influencing gene
expression for example in the context of
cellular reprogramming that i feel like
i didn't really have time to talk about
in this video
but anyway i still hope you've learned
something in this video um thank you to
my patreon supporters
and as always thanks for listening